saturo Gojo is so insanely powerful that
even gig kutami the author of judu kaen
himself had no other choice but to
temporarily completely remove him from
the story during the Shibuya incident
for there to be any Stakes or conflict
left in the story that Gojo wouldn't
just easily solve immediately by himself
however there's one thing that has
really held him back in this fight
against these strong curses which is
trying not to be a mass murderer or if
you want to phrase it a little bit more
nicely I guess his conscience now Gojo
here does accept that he can save every
single person while a monstrous curse is
wreaking havoc however he'll still
always stop short of killing any
innocent bystanders himself right and
his enemies knew this and that's why
they created the perfect plan to seal
Gojo away in the prison realm during the
Shibuya incident so happy Halloween and
of course having Gojo sealed in the
prison realm changed the entire world
world of JSU kaisen as many characters
have hinted at zuro Gojo's power as a
judu sorcerer is pretty much the only
thing preventing tures from completely
overrunning Japan to be precise this era
Sorcerers are supposedly a lot weaker
than those of the past and without
Gojo's amazing Limitless and six ice
powers keeping the curses at Bay the
entire world is at risk which is of
course exactly why it's so bad that the
plan to seal Gojo ended up working but
what if it didn't now as you'll remember
Gojo could have destroyed all of his
attackers in no time at all but his
attack also would have caught the
hundreds if not thousands of innocent
civilians trapped in shabuya with him as
well but what if instead of actually
holding back for them sat Gojo had just
said screw it and got to display his
full power and so if justce once Gojo
had decided to pass on his Batman type
no kill rule how would he Faire against
the combined efforts of Joo Dagon Hanami
choso mahito and his old best friend
ghetto who actually isn't really ghetto
but you you know what I mean now there
are a few possible reasons why Gojo
might decide not to hold back and go all
out here first off maybe his ghetto
senses go tingling off and he realizes
that if he doesn't put an end to his old
pal right then and there no matter what
cost there'll be a lot of casualties
maybe all the train tracks here in
Shibuya reminds him of the Old Trolley
problem in case you're familiar with it
and he does the math and realizes that
he'll save way more people if he
sacrifices all of the train station
people or you know maybe he just wants
to get into the Halloween Spirit by
committing mass murder you know the
reason doesn't really matter what
matters is how much he's going to crush
these curses right here and so let's
start with the first row of combatants
which is the disaster curses now this is
the second time that Gojo had to deal
with Joo and the third time that he's
had to deal with Hanami and so really he
has no more patience at all for any of
the these special great curses in the
actual story he toys with them as he has
always done but not this time around in
fact he's just going to absolutely
obliterate these guys now due to their
teamwork Hanami is able to cancel out
Gojo's curse technique making Joo the
first curse in a while who actually is
able to touch the world's strongest
sorcerer which is a big mistake Now
joo's power is fire and lava which does
burn bright and red but you know what
else is red Gojo's curse technique
reversal R now this insanely strong judu
power pass down through the Gojo family
has the ability to repel things using a
huge shock wave and so Joo has just
grasp onto Gojo's arm and note to the
author gig otami thanks so much for
making these characters Nam so similar
makes it so much easier to to narrate
this but yeah Gojo's grip slightly burns
his sleeve but his single eye barely has
time to process what's happening next
before he sees the Red Dot shining at
the end of Gojo finger and so joo's body
goes flying at an insane speed
unfortunately causing a few innocent
bystanders to spontaneously burst into
flames on the way but hey so far
technically Gojo didn't kill anyone
himself and we're still going to count
those deaths as being caused by joo's
flying fiery body I guess and so the
volcano curse just smacks right into the
barrier outside Shibuya station at such
a speed that he instantly is destroyed
in a fiery explosion but again someday
if enough people fear a volcanic
eruption he'll be born once again so see
you again someday Joo but up next is
Hanami who would have been very
disturbed by his friend's death if he
would see it but since he's only got
these two Twix For Eyes it probably
won't bother him too much and actually
speaking of those Twigs by the time that
he registers that Joo is gone Gojo has
grabbed his eye branches and ripped them
straight out of his head you see the
mangaa gig akutami already wrote Hanami
the perfect death scene so he'll just
get destroyed immediately after this by
being crushed by Gojo's infinite
technique I mean Hanami does love nature
so I think it's just fitting that they'd
be destroyed by a freak of nature now
currently dog on the ocean disaster
curse is shyy hiding behind a post in
the subway station but not for long of
course now you'll know that Dagon holds
power over water the peaceful blue ocean
and it just so happens that Gojo also
has something blue in his Arsenal his
curse technique laps blue and so Dagon
isn't going to be hiding for very long
now because he'll just be pulled towards
Gojo with really immense Force breaking
straight through the pillar and he might
get a few innocent bystanders soaked
along the way but by the time that he
gets to Gojo it's not long before this
poor curse is also turned into Sushi and
in the actual story we eventually get to
see the full range of dagon's actual
Powers there's a reason that he's a
special grade curse along with his
teammates but all you anime viewers will
just have to keep watching to find out
what he can do because in our what if
scenario this guy is just super Deb
right now but the curses have one more
Ally available to buy time for the rest
of the reinforcements to arrive choso
the cursed womb death painting and so
this very powerful combination of a
human and cursed Spirit wants to avenge
his brothers who are the other death
paintings and so using his power of
blood manipulation he fires a shot of
blood at Gojo however as we know Gojo is
is Untouchable I think you look very
touchable okay not Untouchable after all
and so using his Infinity Powers the
blood appears to stop just short of
striking him in the face however in
reality the blood is actually still
approaching him just so slowly that it
will never actually reach him because
it's traveling through the technically
infinite amount of space between any two
objects I mean math is hard I guess now
being not at all hit by Cho's attack
means that Gojo can easily approach the
death painting and eliminate him with
his deadly force pick one you like and
so choso sadly won't get to avenge his
brother but on the bright side he does
get to see them really soon and uh it's
at this point that a subway car rolls
into the station out of course bursts
MTO laughing maniacally as he Reveals
His Train full of transfigured humans
surely Gojo didn't count on this he
thinks before looking around his eyes go
wide as he sees Gojo's beautiful blue
eyes staring back at him and he's
strangely not occupied At All by
fighting the other disaster curses
instead all of maho's friends so far are
like super dead at this point uh-oh uh
how will Gojo now deal with all of these
transfigured humans well kind of similar
to the way that he does in the actual
Story by activating his domain expansion
unlimited void this extension of Gojo's
Limitless ability brings Infinity right
into the minds of everyone exposed to it
it unleashes an infinite amount of raw
information right into the brains of its
victims completely immobilizing them
they feel and see and hear everything
all at the same time and are just
completely overwhelmed left to slowly
die now Gojo's special trick during the
Shibuya incident originally was to of
course spare the normal civilians this
Fate by only activating his domain
expansion for 2 seconds leaving them
just unconscious but not quite killing
them however this time not holding back
his GTO senses are tingling as his old
friend and enemy shows up with the
prison realm and so in an instant he
knows two things one this is not GTO I
totally killed him and two if I let
whoever this impostor is do whatever
they're planning to do things are going
to end up really badly and so you can't
make an omelet without breaking a few
eggs I guess and in this case Gojo's X
are innocent
civilians however along with all of the
regular humans this also takes out mjo's
Legion of transfigured humans as well
and on top of everything of course at
this point Gojo would be big Ms not only
has his besties corpse been taken over
by some sort of evil force but this team
of baddies has gotten him to break his
one rule and kill a bunch of innocent
people and not only does he kill them by
using his domain expansion but he
essentially forces them to suffer for
what feels like eternity he's not about
to let anyone get away with that now m
here can transfigure someone into a
monstrous new form simply by touching
them he does so by actually changing the
shape of their soul itself and the body
just follows this new Twisted shape
however as established it's pretty much
impossible to actually touch Gojo are
you sure about that and let me let me
test out
again proven wrong once again you can be
touched and now you're showing me your
butt how nice what a Gojo thing to do
now Mao's domain expans ion would of
course not have enough power to actually
overcome Gojo's unlimited void and so
failing to touch and transform Gojo Mao
would try to run away but he'd be unable
to make any sort of progress because the
space in front of him would infinitely
extend making it really impossible for
him to get away from Gojo before he was
hit by the full effect of unlimited void
however other than M though pseudo
ghetto is a full other story though
because this sorcerer has been around
the block and knows more than anyone
about Gojo's real abilities and so using
a simple domain he nullifies the effects
of unlimited void and brings the two
back to a more even playing grounds and
so ghetto would use his signature
ability to fight against Gojo as well
which is summoning the curs spirits that
he's captured with his curse technique
however just like everyone else the
spirits would have a very hard time even
hitting Gojo and at this point we're
dealing with an just extremely angry
version of him which is of course the
scariest version of Gojo now he has one
technique left that he's been saving up
and GTO is the perfect person to use it
on and so combining his red and blue
Powers he uses his hollow purple
technique which is the same power that
he developed originally in order to
defeat toif fushiguro and so this
immense blast of pure energy would
absolutely destroy pseudo GTO before he
even gets to tauntingly reveal his evil
brain or his hidden identity
unfortunately Hollow purple would also
absolutely destroy the Shibuya station
and most of the people in it IES now
ultimately You could argue that this
might be worth it based on how many
additional people of Japan this move
would actually save though I'm not about
to get into any moral discussions here
about whether this is ethical or not and
while also remaining somewhat vague
there are probably still going to be
some innocent people who die in Shibuya
whether Gojo kills them or not so the
only difference is whether he gets
sealed and even more people have to to
die eventually and so after the sweeping
finisher move the show would be pretty
much over with the disaster curses and
pseudo ghetto all out of the way the
biggest threats to humanity right now
are gone and judu high school can carry
on business as usual saving Japan from
curses that are not special great you
know just regular run-of-the-mill curses
and so from here on out the focus would
basically be on Yuji going on a quest to
find the remainders of zuna's fingers
and devouring them all like a delicious
gret meal until he's finally executed by
the world worst school administration
like of all time and meanwhile Gojo
would probably be suffering from
crippling PTSD after having killed a
bunch of innocent people by his own
hands or his own curse technique I
should say therapy is obviously a much
smaller price to pay than Japan being
overrun by curses though so hopefully he
can learn to forgive himself and return
to the same old Gojo that we all know
and love and speaking of that Gojo that
we know in love obviously he's one of
the coolest characters in all of anime
but if you want to learn exactly what
makes him such an amazingly written
character you can check out my character
analysis of him right here thanks for
watching